hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Friday the 13th the videogame has
already become a cult classic for many
of us and although the launch was a
little flawed the service has improved
and continues to do so with new features
and bug fixes the devs aren't resting on
their laurels and are busy working on
new features so let's have a look at
nine new things coming to Friday the
13th the biggest news for me is the
introduction of a new Jason to play us
good media are keeping their cards close
to their chest but there are a few hints
that we can look into at present we have
Savini Jason which is a new skin created
for the games founders and retro Jason
designed to look like the Jason from the
NES version back in the 1980s the
full-fledged Jason's are from Friday the
13th part 2 part 3 part 6 part 7 part 8
and 2 part 9 so there's some gaps
missing in the lineage my guess would be
that Jason from Part 5 complete with the
blue Chevron's on his hockey mask yes I
know he isn't really a Jason but hey
cosplay is cool just in case you think
Friday the 13th is all about murder and
feast your eyes on some of the new
emotes being introduced to the game
we've only seen three thus far which
look like a way to beckon a counselor
over to your location
another looks like a flat-out refusal
and the third is a subtle celebration of
a job well done except for Tiffany who
gets who gets the all wrong come on look
there will be a total of eight free
communication emotes coming very soon
back to the gratuitous violence gun
media have revealed behind the scenes
photos of new kill animations coming to
Friday the 13th if you can make out what
the hell is going on here please let me
know except for this one this is
obviously Jason making a pinata out of a
counselor and looking forward to that
one
also coming soon our new outfits for
each counselor - brand spanking new ones
for each in fact some more opportunities
to look unique those of you who want
more clothing options or should I say
less clothing options then look no
further than the Spring Break 1984 [ __ ]
which lets all counselors strip down to
the
trunks and bikinis while being hunted by
Jason
sadly the spring break pack will cost
you real money but whether you spend or
not you will be receiving new cosmetic
items very soon if you are looking for
new destinations to hunt down teenagers
then rest assured that the devs are
working on new maps which will be taken
directly from the movies one of the most
requested locations is based on Jason
Takes Manhattan
part 8 in the saga tracking down pas de
father on the subways and the city
streets could be amazing but maybe a
little too unrealistic in addition new
fast-paced maps have been announced
allowing smaller groups to enjoy the
game instead of waiting for eight
players to join Peconic Crystal Lake and
Higgins Haven will be resized to allow
this the games balancing will also be
changed as a smaller map will help you
find items quicker but it also means
there's less room to escape Jason when
Friday the 13th release we were promised
a single-player campaign to get our
teeth into but over time this looked a
little too ambitious for gun media
months on and work is still underway to
bring us a one player option
but it is coming so we just need to be a
little bit more patient
another aspect promised before the
Friday the 13th release was a kill camp
theater at the end of each game to
showcase the brutal ways Jason took out
the teams this has been much harder to
follow up than I anticipated
but as of last month the highlight reel
function will be coming at the same time
as the single-player portion of the game
so fingers crossed we will still get
this we will soon be getting dedicated
servers for console players which should
mean the overall connectivity should be
improved and the hosts advantage will be
taken away at present host migration is
not being added so console players still
expect the whole stew leave the second
you kill them thus ending the game for
everyone and finally a physical copy of
Friday the 13th is arriving on October
the 13th and guess what it actually is a
Friday the 13th oh my god my OCD loves
that I know this isn't big news to us
because we have the game already but it
should open the door for many more
players hopefully frustratingly the
physical copy
with a new Jason - and new counselor
outfits but don't worry it isn't a full
fledge jason merely a bloody reskin off
part 3 Jason so there you have it 9 new
things coming to Friday the 13th are you
still playing Friday the 13th do you
still love it or maybe you're the one
who's thinking about joining the madness
at Crystal Lake soon I'd love to know
your thoughts about the upcoming content
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]